hi my name is Rob reggae Schofield I am
a user interface architect for Wolfram
research my talk is titled Wolfram
player for iOS and I will be introducing
the iOS version of the Wolfram player
app we recently introduced that is
available now for iPads and iPhones
all right I'd like to thank all of you
for coming my name is Robert guy
Scofield I work at Wolfram research in
the user-interface Department and I am
one of the members of a team who has
been working for a bit of time on this
product that we have just released
called Wolfram Wolfram player for iOS
and that is the app that you're looking
at on the screen right now one thing
that's going to you know be a fairly
significant difference between this talk
and a talk you may have seen me give at
a previous conference is that I'm not
using an app that I built myself on my
computer and transferred onto my iPad
I'm using the app that is available in
the App Store right now and anyone can
go here and download this it's a free
download so I highly recommend everyone
do that and I was just noticing that I
haven't given it a review so I'm just
gonna go ahead and give it a review real
quick so right
this is Wolfram Player and as I said
this is now a released app we've been
working on it for a number of years
several months ago we made it available
to many people who maybe in this room as
a as a beta and we thank many of you for
participating in that program and
submitting to us some valuable feedback
we've been working our way through lots
and lots of issues over the past several
months and as of two weeks ago the app
was finally released and it will run on
both an iPad or iPhone as long as it's
running iOS 9.3 or higher and it is as I
said a free download so you the free app
that you get will display the contents
of arbitrary CDF documents which is
possibly a little bit different from
what I had described in the past
so even dynamic content will now display
for you in the free version whereas
previously dynamic content was just kind
of blocked
now the dynamic content is displayed for
free
you can't immediately interact with it
but I'll get to that in just a second
but you can view and even rotate 3d
graphics in the three vert and the free
version also so if you want to enable
full dynamic interactivity this is
something that's optional and you can do
it in one of three ways that I have
listed here so you can work with
Enterprise CDF documents which is a way
to author the documents so if you have
an Enterprise version of Mathematica
which I think costs a little bit more
money you can sign these CDF documents
and then anyone can look at them and
interact with them for free the second
option is to subscribe to Wolfram cloud
and that will once you log into your
Wolfram cloud account in the app that
will enable all dynamic interactivity
and the third option is just a one-time
in-app purchase about $10 u.s. and that
will enable all dynamic interactivity
for any document for your account so
this app has a number of interesting
features so you can open documents from
anywhere we allow you to log into
Wolfram cloud accounts directly in the
app and I can just give you an example
of that if I go back here this document
that I'm viewing is actually Ana Wolfram
a cloud account so there's a few
different sections I have some locally
stored documents I have a couple of
Wolfram cloud accounts that I'm signed
into you and I can just view all my
files navigate through the folder
hierarchy and go to the file I want and
Here I am you can download files from
the web and if anyone was in the room
before the talk started you may have
seen me do that a couple times I went to
the demonstrations dot Wolfram comm and
was able to go find a demonstration that
I want to look at I'm going to tap the
download link and it's going to ask me
if I want to open that Wolfram player
and I say
yes of course and then I can just view
the file immediately and this is now
stored locally so I can come back to it
if I want without having to go back to
the web the same works for web downloads
also works for email attachments also
works for other cloud services iCloud
Dropbox Google Drive any of those if you
have a CDF or notebook file stored on
any of those services you can get to
them in the app and open the document
directly and then you can also sync
documents with iTunes which is a little
bit more complicated and cumbersome
process but it's the one way to do it
without using some sort of network cloud
service so what what is this app do it
does local computations so the wolfram
engine is embedded inside the app it
doesn't need a network connection to do
any of the computations everything
everything is done locally so the
benefit of that is improve performance
and you can do it when you're offline so
we have user interface and experience
that are appropriate for the platform so
when we have tap targets things like
buttons for instance they're all going
to be finger sized so you can get your
finger on them to tap them you don't
have to necessarily have a very precise
location for a very imprecise pointing
device and the manipulate controls by
default will be positioned at the bottom
of the screen so that you're not having
to cover the content with your hand and
kind of have to look around your hand to
to see what you're actually manipulating
but there's a way to get around that if
that doesn't work for your particular
application so it supports all of the
features of computable documents
typesetting
and I have this the font size there we
go
[Music]
graphics and there these aren't static
bitmaps that are rendered at one size we
can zoom this and it continues to look
nice
as we zoom in as far as we can get here
graphics 3d same sort of thing and this
has the also the feature where we can
rotate the 3d graphics we can toss them
so you can get it going and that will
keep going for a little bit we can use
well so just a single single finger will
rotate it and then you can toss it
yeah no controls and then you can do two
finger gestures to pan the graphic
around and you can pinch to zoom in to
the graphic and as I mentioned earlier
3d graphics viewing and interacting with
them both available in the free version
of Wolfram player so dynamic content
this will you can view and interact with
dynamic content same as you can on a
desktop system if you want to interact
with the dynamic content and what I mean
is to tap on this checkbox and have it
respond to the tab that is what requires
the enhanced functionality which I
mentioned earlier you can get through an
Enterprise CDF or a cloud subscription
or an in-app purchase so I can tap on
this and the document will respond to it
and of course that includes everyone's
favorite manipulate so we tap on the
manipulate and we get controls at the
bottom here and we can interact with the
control without covering it
and there are some features that are
specific to touch that aren't
necessarily meaningful and a desktop
system so on desktop system we have a
function called Mouse position which
always returns a list of XY coordinates
on a touchscreen that's not super useful
because there may not be a current touch
happening or there could be more than
one so we have a new function called
touch position which is an analog to
Mouse position but it could return zero
coordinates or it could return I
actually don't know what the maximum is
but I have tested it and I can
definitely get all 10 fingers on
and then there is an option to
manipulate a which is similar to the
existing control placement option which
we kind of ignore on a touchscreen
because many manipulates authored with
this option we're kind of created
without thinking about a touchscreen so
by default we put the controls at the
bottom if you have a different control
placement that would be better in in
your specific case like here I have an
example that just uses a vertical slider
and I've decided I didn't want to put a
vertical slider at the bottom of the
screen and have it take up you know a
bar all the way across when it's a very
narrow tall thing so I'm going to put it
at the side of the screen instead and I
can do that with this touchscreen
control placement arrow right and I can
[Music]
have my same manipulate with the
controls in a different place there so
we certainly aim for this to be as
compatible as possible with desktop
versions of Mathematica and one thing
that all just note real quick if you
look at the you know the version
information this is version 11.10 clear
for iOS but this is really a version one
product this is kind of a brand new
thing and so there are some ways which
it is not 100% compatible with the
desktop versions of wolfram player so
some of them some of the limitations
that we know about since this is a
player app does not allow content
creation it only allows you to view and
interact with the existing content so
you still need to use either your
desktop version or Wolfram cloud to
create new content and we do have a
Wolfram cloud app for iOS which if you
need to create something on your iOS
device you can use the Wolfram cloud app
and then if you want to interact with
that content in a way that's offline
and/or potentially with
better performance due to the local
computations then you can download it
into the player app and interact with it
there yes yeah
yes you can so we do have support for
input field and as I mentioned in just a
moment it is somewhat more limited than
what it is in the desktop version and
I'll get to that real quick yeah yes if
you look in the title bar the document
that I am using right now is an NB file
so the the one way it makes a
distinction is if you have an enterprise
signed CDF file that will allow you to
do dynamic interactivity for free and
any other file won't ok so we had we do
have some incomplete features that we
know about one is slide shows which I'm
sure many of you have noticed I'm not
using a slide show to display this which
is a little bit unfortunate but we know
about it and it's something that's high
on our priority list to get fixed as
soon as possible
things like event handler we don't have
good support for certain examples of
locator if it's outside of a manipulate
we don't support that at the moment
input field we allow entering of plain
text of numbers but what we don't have
support for is typesetting inside an
input field and things like J link and
database link these are built on top of
Java and these are things that are never
going to work on the iOS version wolfram
player and then one other thing to
consider is performance I have given a
talk somewhat similar to this for a few
years at the conference now and over
that time
I used to say you know be prepared the
performance is going to be nowhere near
what it is on a desktop system and
within the last two years that's kind of
changed dramatically the speed of new
iOS devices in the last two years is
pretty remarkable especially compared to
what it was in the past I have a an
iPhone 7 which has a faster CPU than my
wife's MacBook the new iPhones that were
just released have a faster CPU than a
lot of the MacBook Pros that Apple is
currently selling brand-new so this used
to be a big issue it's less of an issue
anymore especially if you have a device
that's you know less than 2 years old if
you have an older device you could still
run into some performance problems and a
lot of these devices you know keep
running year after year after year and
so people don't necessarily upgrade them
so that's something to think about
you may not get super smooth animation
or you know interactivity if you have an
iPad 3 for example and the older write
devices also had a pretty small amount
of RAM so if you're doing computations
in the wolfram engine that use a lot of
RAM sometimes it runs out and there are
cases where we handle that more
gracefully than others sometimes the
Apple will be just killed by the
operating system and there's not really
anything we can do about it
so if that happens for inexplicable
reasons but you have reason to believe
you know maybe this computation was
using a lot of memory that would be one
way to look at going about trying to to
fix that did you have a question ok
okay I will just say in this particular
app on iOS that isn't an issue because
there's only one in Turkey and we don't
support shift in ur evaluations at all
so the enter is the one and only thing
that we can do sure and one of the
limitation as I'm sure several people
noticed from Stevens talk last night he
killed the kernel a few times when he
was having problems that's not something
that we can really do in the app right
now we can't restart the Wolfram engine
from within the same process at the
moment so if your Wolfram engine runs
away out of control then you kill the
app and you'll have to bring the UI
backup also so we think you know we
spend a fair bit of time on it we think
what we have now available to everyone
is a pretty solid product we're quite
happy with it but as I said this is a
1.0 version despite the fact that it's
version 11 point 2 point 1 but we
received a lot of valuable feedback
during the beta process but since we
released it to the general public that
has increased significantly and we've
just been receiving tons of really
useful feedback lots of things where the
app didn't work is expected or something
didn't you know up here on the screen
exactly the same way as it does on
desktop and people have been reporting
those issues to us and we've been fixing
them so we are going to have more
releases fixing lots of these types of
bugs we've already fixed dozens and
dozens of user reported bugs since the
release two weeks ago we have a version
coming out that's going to use the
Wolfram engine version 11 point 2 right
now it's based on eleven point one so
all the new features in eleven point two
will be available and as I said
slideshow support is something that's
high on our list and
these are things that we all hope to do
by the end of the year and that is a
pretty realistic expectation I think so
what you all can what you all can do is
get the app if you haven't done it
already install the app on your iPhone
or iPad from the App Store you just have
to go to the app store and search for
wolfram player it will show up you can
get it for free you're going to most
likely want to enable full interactivity
as I mentioned we have three ways of
doing that you can work with Enterprise
CDF this is CDF documents created by an
enterprise version of Mathematica those
are interactivity is available to
everyone with those documents regardless
of whether they have a cloud
subscription or an in-app purchase you
can get a cloud subscription that will
enable interactivity in your app once
you sign in with your cloud account that
has this subscription or you can do the
one-time in app purchase in these other
ways you can enable dynamic
interactivity once you do that you can
take your content with you
through any number of ways I mentioned
earlier you can download them through a
web browser through a cloud file system
like iCloud Dropbox Google Drive you can
get them through email you can sync them
with iTunes anything like that take your
documents with you and then please if
you see problems you see things that
don't look right report those issues to
us and we will do our best to improve
the compatibility